يعطيكم العافيه يا جماعه انا كنت متواجد
في مدينه خانيونس لاكثر من 100 يوم عشتها
بكل تفاصيلها جميع اشكال الحرب قدام عيه
من قصف مدفعي لقصف حربي لاشتباكات لسماع
صوت الاليات لتحذر المربعات للاحزمه
الناريه العنيفه جميع اشكال الحرب عشتها
بكل حذافيرها وبكل تفاصيلها بعد هذه المده
اجيت لمدينه رفح ونزحت بعد ما تحاصرنا في
مدينه خانيونس لفتره يومين وحاليا انا
متواجد في مدينه رفع على بعد من 200 ل 300
متر من الحدود الم والوضع شبه امن لكن
اللي تفاجات منه انه انا اصبحت غير قادر
على التعايش مع الوضع الامن على اساس انه
وضع معتاد بالنسبه لي انا متعود على
الحياه اللي فيها تصحى على صوت القصف صوت
الدمار صوت الاشياء المرعبه واصبحت الامور
الحاليه والوضع الطبيعي باشياء ممله
بالنسبه لي وهذا اشياء يعني هذا شيء غلط
انا بحس فيه وبعرف انه هذا اشياء نفسيه ما
بنفع احس فيها الحرب غيرت حاجات نفسيه
فينا صعب اوصف لكم اياها بطريقه انا متاسف
على هالقول لكن اصبحنا مرضى نفسيين فعلا
ه